êtes vous obligé de vous raser le crâne
se raser la tête c'est pas une
obligation c'est un choix personnel mais
a priori les moines et les nonnes
ça fait partie de leur voeux se rase le
crâne
pourquoi alors se raser la tête c'est un
signe très symbolique
on coupe les illusions en fait les
cheveux ont toujours été considéré comme
un attribut de beauté depuis tout temps
comme un objet de décoration et là
l'idée c'est de montrer son véritable
visage
donc c'est une pratique qu'on fait de
manière ritualisé chaque semaine et
d'ailleurs dans les temps que les moines
et les nonnes se rasant fin des moines
sera sept entre eux et les nonnes dans
les temples où il ya des nonnes ce sera
sept entre elles mêmes les femmes ont le
crâne rasé puis on ne porte pas de
bijoux ni de fin de maquillage pour les
femmes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va souvent des moines bouddhistes en
tenue rouge orange c'est la thèse
officielle
voilà ça s'appelle la couleur safran
alors c'est la tenue officielle pour les
moines
d'asie du sud est les moines tibétains
des traditions tibétaines sont plutôt en
orange ocre les moines zen les la
tradition à laquelle j'appartiens de
mono bouddhisme zen soto on est en noir
donc ça dépend de la tradition la
couleur va dépendre on va distinguer les
différentes traditions du bouddhisme par
les couleurs en fait y'a combien de
tradition je connais pas toutes les
traditions mais c'est vrai qu'en france
on connaît surtout le bouddhisme par le
biais de moines tibétains avec la figure
du derrière ma de matthieu ricard
on connaît très peu les autres branches
mais il y en a beaucoup il ya du
bouddhisme vietnamien coréens japonais
est ce que vous devez considérer qu'un
en dieu non il n'est pas considéré comme
un dieu elle est considérée comme un
homme on l'appelle souvent même le grand
médecin
en fait c'est un homme qui s'est
éveillée à sa véritable nature
il a il a une clarté évidente sur sur
certaines choses et il a voulu le
proposer aux êtres humains
il a proposé une voie spirituelle pour
se libérer de la souffrance
comment les rémunérer un moine
bouddhiste un moine bouddhiste n'est pas
rémunéré par sa pratique dans le sens où
il peut avoir une vie sociale
il peut travailler la lionne son argent
comme tout le monde
alors il ya des traditions effectivement
où les moines ne peuvent pas travailler
ce qui pose un problème en france et en
europe plus largement c'est à dire qu en
asie
les moines pratiquent la mendicité et
faites les gens des villages vont donner
de des offrandes de la nourriture pour
les moines c'est une pratique courante
qui se fait on va souvent les moines
défiler dans la rue avec un bol les
chrétiens l'habile ibg font également la
torah les musulmans le coran il existe
les bouddhistes ils ont l'enseignement
de leurs maîtres et l'enseignement
général de la de la communauté
c'est une transmission orale à c'est pas
une transmission écrite le bouddhisme né
en inde 500 ans avant jésus-christ et
puis c'est donc ça fait près de 2600 ans
qui se transmet uniquement de maître à
disciple l'alcool l'alcool c'est pas
interdit
là où il faut faire attention c'est les
conséquences de notre consommation donc
évidemment si on tombe dans l'excès et
ben faut être encore plus attentif on
dit dans le bouddhisme il faut pas
s'intoxiquer le corps et l'esprit
il ya mille et une manières de
s'intoxiquer un surtout l'esprit qui
sont plus grave qu'un verre de vin
canton s'intoxiquent avec la colère avec
l'égoïsme avec l'avidité ou avec des
idéologies extrêmes
c'est beaucoup plus grave que
d'apprécier un verre de vin avec ses
amis alors il ya des traditions
bouddhistes qui ne boivent pas du tout
d'alcool dans la tradition c'est
possible est ce que vous regardez les
séries si je regarde les séries je
regarde beaucoup de séries michael
dernièrement j'ai regardé la famille
type celle que j'ai adoré j'ai regardé
le serpent si avec tarime que j'adore
malheureusement très fan de séries c'est
pour ça que je lis de moins en moins
d'ailleurs vous marier on peut se marier
dans la tradition il ya des moines qui
sont mariées adenon donc ils pratiquent
ensemble qui ont un parcours de vie
commun travers la spiritualité
il ya des moines qui sont mariés à des
laïcs aussi ou à d'autres religieux
tout est possible dans d'autres
addition et veulent s'y installer il ya
des traditions bouddhistes ou
effectivement certains les moines font
voeu de chasteté quels sont les clichés
sur votre religion à des clichés on a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup mais ça qui
me vient en premier enfin celui qui
vient en premier c'est l'image du but du
bouddhiste gentil où tout est amour non
c'est pas c'est pas ça un bouddhiste est
un être humain comme les autres qui a
choisi une voie spirituelle qui n'est
pas simple il a ses travers
il a aussi ses moments de colère ces
moments de voilà de souffrance tous les
bouddhistes ne sont pas gentils et est
beau il ya d'autres il ya deux clichés
sur sur les termes du bouddhisme sur le
des mots un peu galvaudé comme le karma
qu'on confond souvent par exemple avec
le destin le nirvana qu'on comprend pour
un lieu paradisiaque
c'est quoi le plus dur dans les rues
d'amman lui dise aujourd'hui de rompre
avec l'instant présent mais bon ça se
sait c'est ce qu'il ya de plus dur pour
tout le monde je pense que l'attention
c'est devenu une denrée rare
on voit bien quand on est sur internet
et quand on y va pour chercher
l'information et qu'on se retrouve a
acheté une paire de sneakers c'est que
bon il ya effectivement un problème
d'attention et ça c'est quand même la sq
est au coeur de notre pratique le moment
présent donc c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
dur à pratiquer de revenir sans cesse au
corps au souffle parce que c'est ce qui
a plus concret c'est ce qu'il ya de
mieux pour nous ramener à l'instant
présent